insulate britain you may have seen this
today they block sections of the m25 for
the fifth time in a week and they say
actions will continue until the
government commits to insulating homes
but
is this disruptive form of protest
damaging their cause uh juliet what do
you think good thing bad thing
well so look insulation is actually a
topic close to my heart you know 20 of
emissions in the uk at greenhouse gas
emissions come from the warming of the
places we live in and we work in so it's
an issue so thank you yes shine a light
on it when they first did this in august
the first protest yeah
okay well let's ask george then because
george this is what the police said
today protesters have put their own
lives as well as those of others at risk
i mean stopping traffic on the m25 is
hugely dangerous it's a pretty stupid
way to get your message out there isn't
it
you have to draw attention to this issue
and civil disobedience is an essential
way of doing so it's been an essential
protest tactic all the way through the
suffragettes gandhi martin luther king
when you have an issue which is being
comprehensively neglected by those in
power you have to use the most powerful
means at your disposal to try to get it
on the front page in front of people's
minds and
disruptive civil disobedience has time
and again proved to be that most
powerful means and of course it is
inconvenient to people but while we're
talking about the inconvenience on the
m25 just a couple of days ago motorways
in france were flooded probably as a
result of climate breakdown and that
took an awful lot longer to clear and
that is a glimpse of the future we're
going to have repeatedly
unless we start to bring in
radical aims insulate britain's core
yeah juliet like
suffragettes
well i just went to their website
there's no information on how i can
actually insulate better give me some
tools
oh you mean on their website you you're
not getting the information you need
even if you wanted to insulate yeah okay
i i get that i get that point i mean
george i have to say one uh person on
the radio this morning was saying he was
trying to drive his mother to hospital
because she'd had a stroke they got to
hospital hours late and as a result
she's partially paralyzed
well i i'm really sorry to hear that and
you know obviously
yeah um you know bad stuff does happen
but you know we're facing disruption
which is going to be killing hundreds of
millions of people unless we get a grip
on this you know this this is huge i
mean i don't think anyone really can get
their head around
the level of suffering which we're
likely to experience unless we stop
climate breakdown from happening and it
seems to me that the only people who are
taking it seriously
are protesters who are almost putting
their lives on the line
to try to draw attention to the massive
neglect of this issue by those in power
and these protests would not be
necessary
if those in power were actually
interested in saving lives and stopping
the catastrophe which is coming our way